Nicole used to be a competitive skier
that's why she's so good at taking
double blacks Andy was molested as a
young schoolboy he graduated top of his
class and bottom of his teacher
it was my babysitter and at least I got
something out of a hookup
Nicole the booger of the Comedy
Store and the only thing she got on the
wall was her face pressed against it
Andy looks like a slave owner who would
be really bummed if his slaves didn't
want to hang out with him
[Music]
that's not how slaves work they don't
have a choice Oh last show you guys
Nicole is actually pretty excited about
the Trump wind because when he starts
deporting illegal immigrants she'll get
more shifts at the Costco she passes
samples out at and he just hates Costco
cuz his ex-wife was guys in bulk
[Applause]
Andy and his ex-wife had an open
marriage
that's a hipster term for I can't make
my wife come
that'll do everybody that's the last out
of the night long
a lot of dirty laundry aired
indefinitely the vicious battle of the
night give it up for these two yeah so
funny that was great Annie is super
funny I think you should meet my homey
and it's stand-up it's so funny but I
thought you cleaned him out Nicole I
thought you took him all the right yeah
no sorry I mean it was funny both
funding some good jokes of double blacks
was really funny but I thought that uh
Nicole that with you everyone was it was
that fire and I'm not just saying that
as another Jew I'm saying that as a fan
of you it's fierce although it does not
help that Andy looks like what Hitler
jerked off to it's my first credit that
was a good I enjoyed that battle a lot
and Andy I appreciate the during the
white guy starter kit uh I like Nicole
in this one Andy I get it I did like
your meanness and everything but you
know she counterpunched on one of your
jokes on the Costco joke yeah and that
was like whoa what the that was it
right there that was no that was great
it's a comic I realized like oh she must
have really worked at Costco at some
point to have him to have had such a
quick as I was like damn she's like a
super genius if she didn't work
at a Costco but I work at a cost okay
that was a great call back Nicole I
could see how hard you worked on this
and II seem like you're gonna
take out a gun and kill us all no I talk
about my ex-wife guys on stage
already and II just looks like that yeah
I'm very low in the spectrum I know
you're a great roast battle fan Andy
you're super funny comic and thank you
for doing this but I do think Nicole I
got our almost perfect score tonight so
you all new tonight congratulation she
was just solid she had great jokes all
around a night I got I got nervous you
know I'm not used to being around women
so yeah I'm not used to being around
vegans
[Applause]